io so come turismo episodio o guys un
gioco veramente bello fatto solo per
lanciare i joystick mesco vediamo se
riusciamo a fare una partita decente
anche oggi cosa abbastanza probabile
perché stamattina mi è arrivato mi è
arrivato un messaggio da pietro che mi
diceva oggi ho giocato a for guys e ho
vincoli già vinto pietro non è forse
vincere anche les combes
partiamo ray stupisce ballo anche visto
che mappa è acqua le porte ok
niente nessuno stai calmo e dal
direttore dell'inca marco carboni
allora partiamo male ragazzo che bello
su gufo bye bye bye
prima ero prima se non ho capito sono
arrivato primo 68 primo non sa neanche
come perché 60 anni nello scalare
entrato ogni portami scaraventava in
modo diverso non sono anche con fatto
arrivare primo se non vado errato in
bloccarti io lo dico sempre però ogni
volta che lo dico rischio che i campani
ammazzi non sono mai caduto quindi
speriamo di continuare con questa
questo primato pazzesco punto veramente
coupé rimasto ancora in piedi benissimo
sto provando ragazze vedere se le
scansioni sul cornicione perché si fa
così male bisogna saltare sulle persone
e vedere se però non biondi io scherzavo
però il problema è che secondo me come
l'avevo detto nell'ultimo nel penultimo
episodio l'hanno fissata st rocca vacca
ce l'hanno fissata sicuro perché piace
un sacco di gente che riusciva ad esso
non ci riesce fine sono quindi si curano
fissata buono adesso ci dovrebbe essere
la schermaglia finale arrivano il 26
mila blocchi tutti insieme e poi cade un
sacco di gente però eliminati sono i sei
ragazzi abbiamo bisogno di almeno 15
eliminati meno 15 buono
eccola qua speriamo di non essere la
schermatura finale pasta impastare la
mantia casa sempre avanti
sembravamo questo libro è quindi un
piano
bravo luciano che mi stai queste quindi
luciano bravo bravo non mi toccare chi
deluso la bravissimo lo ha visto quanta
gente caduta 17 perfetto l'effetto è
andata anche meglio di quanto pensassi 9
reining siamo rimasti teoricamente per
l'ultima no forse c'è ancora la
semifinale speriamo lo faccia col gol
che vi mette sicuramente nella squadra
con meno gente i suoi amici 9
tutto tranne fourballs almeno non è
sempre così è sempre in quella con meno
gente almeno non nei gialli ora questo
gioco veramente se non mi prende per il
culo lui porco demonio non lo so io
veramente non ho parole
non ho parole sempre quello che ho detto
l'ho detto esatto ho detto esattamente
guardano esce col bolle vado in quello
con meno gente è uscito parole
incredibile quante probabilità ci sono e
se nome ragazzi sempre così dovete
capire sempre così a pablito che la fa
finita stessa bravo madonna luciano che
sogno che sogno ti prego no ma cosa
storta michiara ga 20 bravissimi miglior
sono scarsi una morte vai perfetto 0
madonna ragazzi un fenomeno ancora
ancora fronimo ancora una dove che
accade che cade mezzo borja ma crollano
fregata ancora con questa con questa
dribbling butta in mezzo sono imbalsato
io sulla palla però port coleman ragazzi
ho fatto la partita perfetta
ho fatto la partita perfetta ve lo giuro
perché ho fatto tutti oro primo sono
arrivato primo nel secondo e nel terzo
da bloc party perfect match che mi hanno
fatto arrivare primo perché lì non c'è
bisogna rivedere in bassa che sopravvive
qua devi fare almeno dieci gol e li ho
fatti tutti oro finale in quattro anche
se full monty va bene se vinco
se vinco la partita perfetta se vinco la
partita per ragazzi ho fatto la partita
perfetta se vinco perché ho fatto tutti
oro tutti primo nel primo primo nel
secondo nel terzo e nel quarto sempre
primo con con la con la medaglia d'oro
se arrivo primo ho fatto la partita
perfetta
luciano luciano lasciami non c'è perché
per le views cava grazie luciano nicchia
il colpo è partito male attenzione
attenzione che do io
va bene
minchia vediamo veramente scusa al
meglio concentrare sul suo sito mi
concentro lezioni concerto più zitti
cazzo sono gli altri
la donna
è vero bravo no il gradino no no no non
è vero non ci credo mai non ci credo mai
andata giù è caduto dai no no no no no
no no no no no no no no marco demarco
fatto ma cosa vi fa l'occhiolino che ho
fatto 66 gol nel fourball no ragazzi
guardate vi prego horror ora loro perso
per un millimetro ma è un ragazzo che
abbiate joystick perché l'auto stava
morendo
il problema è che non riuscirò mai più
mai mai più a fare una preghiera
perfetta lo primo primo primo primo
secondo per un niente poi maledizione
solo perché quel cupo cia gli occhiali
enormi e andava nato caprina col ora
partiamo col sito
cerchiamo di gianpi mentino abbastanza
veloce anche tanto cerco sempre di
ritagliarvi poi lanzi con la partita
agli inizi che sono rotto le palle è
perfetto è variato anche secondo tra
l'altro lo stack agata oggi non so che
cacchio shop
ma tra il primo e non posso più fare
tutta la partita perfetta e salviato
secondo però comunque sto notando che
oggi per qualche strana maniera ci sono
più del solito quindi vediamo se
coltivando così porto dei risultati e da
un botto che non facciano all'auto posso
anche sacrificarmi e farlo a free allora
guai è legge
la tattica sonorità è quella di rimanere
tra il primo e il secondo e saltare sui
numeri sempre dato il nostro rendeva
ripeto ogni tanto di lord progetto 66
volte basta basta spiegare tattili
giochiamo e basta perfetto attenzione e
ho preso al muro fratelli ed hanno così
mi chiamano anche cadendo ho rischiato
pure come non so cosa di peccati cadere
dopo dai manca uno a maggio ragazzi la
gente è diventata sempre più esperta in
corso perché se ci fate caso c'è sempre
ok
c'è sempre gente che cade si sente
sempre di più a cadere la gente rispetto
all'inizio quindi pure difficile man
mano la gente si sta squillando mi è
sempre più difficile andare avanti
niall cacchio si dei signori meno male
cinesi ragazzi come dico sempre è la mia
preferita perché la tattica giusta
inutile di rimanere da una parte
dall'altra in egual numero di componenti
della sua de melo tale da ottimizzare
era quasi a meno quattro gialli come
siamo abbastanza quindi usiamo io
rimango qua non ci siamo inventati
cunicolo gialli sempre che alla
matematica avanti 34 pari tutti 34 pari
tutti minchia raga occhio predosa
bravissimi non sto ragazzino stop
rendono uno ma neanche uno sto facendo
schifo
ora che la partita più brutta di utility
che abbia mai fatto da quando c'è questa
roba è pazzesco e orribile
eccolo marevero aiuta ma non è vero
6 ecco qua un cerchio 1 o latino prezzi
veramente 394 veramente pochi mamma mia
e l'unica volta nella mia vita
specialmente in un sì lei si dove la
squadra è più forte di me io sono quello
che fa schifo una particolare è stato
mai successo mai 14 the many se non ci
faccia fare hexagon è privo il gufo è là
che partì lo so io lo so ma già molto
brava minuti 0 persone un altro zitti
mito concentrare va bene più o meno se
dianzi però togliti turco la lingua del
culo mickey è caduto togliti minchia che
ansia di via bravo o estero è questa ho
vinto questa che mi meritavo più vari
prima perché qua ho giocato male la
prima partita e poi l'isaf al monte è
andato abbastanza bene ma sono caduto un
paio di secondo me lo meritavo piccola
di prima per carità son contento è per
convinto anche stavolta però nella prima
partita tutti ora è né l'ultimo arrivato
secondo
vabbè nell'ultima tutti ora anche
l'ultimo vinto e la prima sul reato
secondo la cosa però mi sia piaciuto
questa non la pensano i fall gay se
cerchiamo prossimo lunedì e giovedì
ricorda che ci sono i piedi for guys
oppure vi trovate il martedì giovedì e
la domenica mattina su the morning e
ming che sono sempre in lei cosa hai da
ragazzi dove ti è piaciuto è stato e mi
piace scritte dal calare e noi ci
vediamo cos'è della ragazza
[Musica]